so it made me of course reuniting with
John and Alexis Shakespeare goes back to
the very beginning for you with Joss the
sinner actually my first audition scene
for angel was a scene he wrote based on
Midsummer Night's Dream with Alexis and
and J August Richards so that you know
all the people who are saying it's weird
that Joss is doing Shakespeare and
that's kind of what I've known him from
for the beginning are we talking to
Alexis before I was saying to him if you
would like to do another Shakespeare
movie with Joss after this what would it
be and he said Hamlet with Joss in the
lead role what do you think about that I
I'm in for sure we did a reading of
Hamlet at Josh's house where he played
Hamlet and it was it was great so I
think that would be really fun I don't
know you'll have to convince Joss I
think his acting skills something that
we all need to sing yes I mean you know
you've got to see bits and pieces of my
my first time I met Joss was on one of
the first times I met him on Angel he
was dressed in full green makeup and he
had been dancing in the background and
he came up to me and I had no idea that
it was just me you know I was like oh
I'm sorry is this your chair he was like
big fancy guy over now of course the
French and princely get that happy
ending like bu yeah I mean working with
Alexis is one of my favorite things in
the world but I'm probably not special
to say that I think anyone who works
with him feels the same way but it's
it's you know we had such a great time
together on angel and Joss would come in
and write scenes for Alexis and I crept
so it's he didn't even write and come
and direct us so we the three of us have
always enjoyed working together and I
think this was just a really great
excuse to do it again a nice member of a
moment from the film tonight much ado
I you know every time no what I really
love is that every time there's a new
character that pops out at me and the
last time I watched it I was just in
love with Fran Kranz Claudio so I'm
excited to see who popped out tonight
well enjoy the screening tonight it'll
be sweet Jane thank you
you